you
[Music]
I've been in belgium for four years
but julien from sony
here it's going up this model
distributes hot drinks to
answer migrants yes for
people whose good people are
welcome we note that my skin is therefore
me
but  m like those of love
the loss is to disappear like that we were
going to give up shares and x6
we succeeded
m
[Music]
I'm doing liquor launches in public and
international law and my goal is to finish my
studies to work because I  I
want to work in this field and
I didn't throw my past life in
the water this profession the lawyer too what does
he do he is also he is for
people who come to explain to
people what is  market we need to do
[Music]
I will be in this area and send back
as a new case but in addition we
must be in solidarity with other
issues
[Music]